ce pouvoir a échoué on parlait de sa
gestion chaotique catastrophique de la
crise sanitaire mais on pourrait avoir
le même bilan sur la sécurité avec des
chiffres qui se dégrade de tous les
jours sur l'immigration où on a franchi
des des records sur l'économie où on n'a
pas fait les réformes structurelles je
parle avant la crise nécessaire donc
pourquoi s'allier avec un pouvoir qui a
échoué et que nous combattons moi je
suis pour les idées claires et pour des
idées simples c'est ça la crédibilité de
la parole publique ans à confusion
eh bien on sait pas où je contribuerai à
faire en sorte que la droite
républicaine dont les idées sont
majoritaires ne soit pas mise à l'écart
du débat et portent l'espérance d'une
alternance
la france a besoin d'une alternance
emmanuel macron a échoué il a échoué
gravement pour le pays il affaiblit le
ps que voguerez donc il faut une
alternative et senna a fait ce qu aurait
ce que j'aurais rêvé faire à l'assemblée
nationale tous ces amendements qui
viennent d'être adoptées par le sénat et
je salue le courage des sénateurs qui
les ont portés
je les avais défendu à l'assemblée
nationale ils ont été tous rejetés
systématiquement de façon monolithique
par monsieur darmanin et par les députés
en marche
pourquoi parce que ce texte malgré les
grands discours
c'est finalement qu'un petit
bouillonnement à l'eau tiède eux il ya
eu des demi-mesures des mesurettes
rien de très audacieux rien de très
courageux on n'a même pas osé parler
d'islamisme le mot de figure pas dans le
projet de loi du gouvernement
tellement on avait peur de cette audace
de s'attaquer à l'homme aux toqués par
le conservatoire elle néanmoins quoi
enfin texte parce que l'islamisme est
une idéologie à l'égal du nazisme qui
menace la survie de notre civilisation
le danger est là c'est c'est au-delà
d'un problème religieux c'est un
problème d'une idéologie mortifère de
destruction de la civilisation de
l'humanité et on n'ose pas dénoncé
attaquer clairement fort à lille forum